Was passiert eigentlich wenn uns eine Alienbotschaft
erreicht?
Nichts?
Oder wird die Menschheit ins Chaos gestürzt?
Gerät in Panik?
Oder die komplette Computer-Kommunikations-Infrastruktur
zerstört?
Zwei Forscher haben sich jetzt mit allen möglichen
Szenarien beschäftigt.
Und ich kann nur sagen.
Demnach wird es nicht gut ausgehen.
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich hochspannende Science-Videos.
Nur wenn ihr den Kanal abonniert verpasst
ihr kein Video.
Herzlich willkommen!
Stephen Hawking warnte davor.
Die Kontaktaufnahme mit Aliens.
Sie könnten feindselig sein und unsere Spezies
vernichten.
Und gegenüber der Schöpfung wäre dieser
Akt sogar gut.
Denn im Moment hausen wir auf der Erde als
gäbe es kein Morgen.
Und das im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Die Vernichtung der Menschheit wäre von diesem
Standpunkt aus betrachtet gar nicht so absurd.
Der Klimawandel könnte damit vielleicht noch
aufgehalten werden.
Punkt für die Aliens.
Aber so oder so könnten sie feindselig sein
und die Erde für sich haben wollen.
Das Ende der Menschheit würde drohen.
Zwei Wissenschaftler haben sich jetzt erstmals
mit etwas vermeintlich viel harmloseren beschäftigt.
Einer Botschaft von Aliens.
Was könnte sie enthalten?
Und was wären die Folgen jeweils.
Horror-Szenario 1: Die Aliens stiften Panik.
Eine sehr einfache und effektive Methode.
Und wir können uns heute gar nicht ausmalen
welche perfiden Botschaften das sein könnten
um eine Massenpanik auszulösen.
Sie müsste nicht mal stimmen.
Allein ein Inhalt, der ein grausames Szenario
beschreibt, dass dann nicht mal eintreten
müsse, könnte dann zum Tod von Milliarden
Menschen führen und das Ende der Menschheit
einläuten.
Lediglich wenn die Botschaft nur an einem
Ort empfangen werden würde und die Verbreitung
in der Folge vermieden werden könnte… nur
dann könnte dieses Szenario verhindert werden.
Wenn allerdings die Botschaft gezielt so verbreitet
wird, dass möglichst viele Menschen erreicht
würden, dann wäre die Massenpanik nicht
mehr zu verhindern.
Es könnte die stärkste Waffe von Aliens
gegen die Menschheit sein.
Sie müssten keinerlei Waffen einsetzen, nur
unsere Psyche zur Selbstzerstörung aktivieren.
Horror-Szenario 2: Die Nachricht enthält
Computer-Viren.
Auch hierfür müsste vermieden werden, dass
die Botschaft viele Menschen und damit Computer
erreicht.
In dem Moment, in dem sich ein solcher Virus
verbreitet könnten die Folgen grausam sein.
Die komplette Infrastruktur des Planeten könnte
zerstört werden.
Mit einem Mausklick.
Verhindert könnte das nur mit einer Analyse
auf dem Papier oder mit einem abgeschotteten
Computer.
Allerdings wäre Papier zu aufwendig und,
dass ein Computer wirklich abgeschottet ist,
ist theoretisch zwar möglich, aber kann sehr
einfach umgangen werden.
Und Forscher und Forscherinnen weltweit machen
immer wieder auf ein noch anderes Problem
aufmerksam: Mit Nachrichten von der Erde aus,
könnten feindliche Aliens angelockt werden.
Wer darf solche Nachrichten also aussenden?
Müssen sie genehmigt werden?
Wer entscheidet darüber?
Logischer Schluss solcher Überlegungen: Eigentlich
muss die Menschheit darüber abstimmen, ob
solche Botschaften ausgesendet werden dürfen
oder nicht.
Die NASA und viele Astrophysiker und Astrobiologen
sind sich sicher, dass wir in den nächsten
rund 20 Jahren auf Aliens stoßen werden.
Wie und wo?
Das ist vollkommen unklar.
Aber schon jetzt gibt es ja schon einen Hinweis,
dass das interstellare Objekt Oumuamua von
einer extraterrestrischen Spezies stammen
könnte.
Das Exklusiv-Interview dazu mit dem Entdecker
der mysteriösen Eigenschaften des interstellaren
Objektes Havard-Professor Abraham Loeb gibt
es im Original auf unserem englischen Kanal
hier: Dafür einfach drauf klicken und den
Kanal auch am besten für solche Videopremieren
abonnieren, denn nur dann verpasst ihr garantiert
nichts.
Dafür hier klicken.
Ansonsten Stay tuned, see you soon.